hey guys I'm Ryan Wright and I am javi
javi and I are going to check out the
video Star Wars Episode 7 the force
awakens the official Instagram sneak
peek I was one of those people who was
like hey it's only 15 seconds is this
really worth doing a video about
apparently most subscribers do you think
it's worth doing so and you're into Star
Wars areum much into yes yes
you saw Attack of the Clones twice
didn't you like midnight then like 6
a.m. I forgot about yeah I did and I
remember the next morning when the fake
princess Amidala coming off the stairway
and this [ __ ] blew up the film went out
and everyone in the theater lost their
[ __ ] I'm like I'm so glad I saw this the
night before it's so cool wow you just
brought back memories that was crazy
yeah your family
there's been an awakening
[Music]
ah [ __ ] you Instagram you and your
15-second video yeah I didn't know he
was a Jedi greg reveal oh my god I'm
like all full of goosebumps great reveal
oh yeah leave it there toy like Luke
Skywalker in him Luke Skywalker
impersonates a stormtrooper black
Skywalker that's awesome
guy walk that's so cool you know people
are gonna think we're races just for
point out the fact that he's black I'm
cheering it on that I'm sure on I see
more blacks in Star Wars yes please all
black Star Wars cast first spin-off
Family Matters meets Star Wars I just
had this word arbitrary I thought like
what if Kevin Hart was in Star Wars
there's a fumbling Jedi people might be
against that night before people would
be totally against it would it be kind
of amazing it would be pretty amazing
Kevin I could blend into any amira I
didn't know he's a Jedi that kind of
blows my mind yeah I wasn't expecting
that at all either I kind of wish they
didn't show that damn it's like it's
Luke parts to my mind it's like well
that's really cool but I didn't want to
know until the movie came out because he
was in the stormtrooper outfit I thought
it was a defecting stormtrooper this
just seems like it's gonna be such an
epic film
it's weird cuz I'm so wanted to don't
feel like epic films to me no no but the
terrible but this looks like it's gonna
be epic you got so many different
elements that way you got returning cash
you got new casts and they managed to
bring back old cast and make us go yeah
and then also get us really intrigued by
her the new players are too anyway yeah
that's our five minute talk about a
15-second video if you guys are new to
the channel you can subscribe to the
real rejects you can check out Jabby
Kawai on the jab eco a channel just type
in YouTube page calm calm and I just saw
Gabby cows short film way of the saber a
Star Wars fan made short film it's
seriously really awesome I was so
impressed I didn't know what to say
check that out like as soon as you can
and if you guys are having followed us
on our social networks yet Facebook
Instagram Twitter vine Paris
so follow us there jab eco a real
rejects you know how it is dogs because
if we get enough followers we can get
even more product placement you know
what I said if I can get enough if I can
get enough going with YouTube and short
films and whatnot I'm gonna amass money
from a Kickstarter to do a fan film of
Star Wars versus Star Trek like a legit
one that's pretty cool but you
interrupted my segue into the product
placement let's be like dude what's the
product placement well now I lost my
trainer I usually pick up a prop what's
your price again I could be like Oh
green tea green tea is Grover the kind
of uses black tea black tea is great you
know the another thing that's also great
that come from the blacks is there's
huge huge testicles they got big
testicles and small penises that's how
the cliche goes yeah fill it in this
bottle and you drink it black tea more
like black pee that is what really
provides you in nutrients it'll make you
pee it really isn't a product placement
from like team this is more like why
people's urine I'm promoting I don't
know where this is going I'm just this
is what happens you interrupt me there's
a peon running